the reason that's small and new YouTube
channels fail is they don't embrace the
law of sacrifice here's the quote from
The Art of War who wishes to fight must
first count the cost I think that a lot
of small YouTube creators underestimate
the amount of energy and time and
emotions and willpower it takes to
really start a YouTube channel and one
of the reasons we can know for sure that
the majority of people
underestimate the level of sacrifice
needed to succeed on YouTube is because
critics say oh YouTubers why don't you
get a real job that very common
statement reveals that a lot of people
have no clue the amount of grit and work
and mental energy and mental toughness
and time it takes to start a successful
YouTube channel the strategy the
planning the learning the skill building
and so one of the big reasons that new
and small YouTube channels fail is they
don't embrace the law of sacrifice
what's the law of sack sacrifice in
order to go up you've got to give up I
think that sometimes we think that we
can kind of just dabble on the side with
the channel and we'll just get lucky and
it'll just blow up and we'll just go
viral and then we hear one or two
stories of that happening and we think
that maybe that'll happen to us the
truth is that's not that common what's
more common is people consistently
uploading over weeks months oftentimes
years continuing to learn continuing to
figure out branding and online marketing
and online business and really honing in
their strategy and there's a lot of
times a Tipping Point study any of the
great video podcasts or podcasts or
YouTube channels and oftentimes they'll
say yeah it was year three it was year
four it was year seven when momentum
really started to pick up and it wasn't
year seven of giving like a half-hearted
effort for the first six years it was
actually seizing the opportunity it was
starting and actually being committed to
consistency over a period of time time
that led to the Breakthrough what are
you willing to sacrifice for the success
of your YouTube channel I'm not saying
you should sacrifice the things that
matter most in life of course you have
priorities like your health and your
family and your kids or whatever your
dependents or responsibility is but can
you sacrifice some entertainment can you
sacrifice some Leisure are you willing
to sacrifice some wasted time are you
willing to sacrifice scrolling on social
media I'm not talking about building
your business I'm just talking about
scrolling randomly instead of studying
or recording your next most important
video I think that a lot of small
channels want to get disproportionate
success results without putting in the
necessary amount of work said
differently than necessary amount of
sacrifice two things number one I've had
too much coffee today number two if you
have not seen our free master class yet
you're gonna love it if you're serious
about growing your YouTube channel just
go to
thinkmasterclass.com for a one hour Deep
dive on-demand YouTube strategy class
it's sick and uh I'm gonna go refill my
coffee hope to see you on the class